it's it's irrelevant people oppose it
it's a single biggest losing issue for
Barack Obama
so when Barack Obama says well you know
how do people think I'm gonna be a
tyrant I'm not I'm only over another
year that's really listen he thinks
you're stupid that's what bothers me
he thinks he's so clever and you're an
idiot that you go well gee I guess he
only has a year then that's the end of
it
the laws stay dummy this week is pretty
big so I want to talk about this because
there was the Obama presser and then the
Anderson Cooper sit-down sort of do we
call that a town-hall yeah it was
something other than that we're still
working on it we're still working on the
title because it was kind of like an
invite-only anyway one thing before we
get into some of the arguments and I
understand there's misinformation on
both sides here is what is so pivotal
when people say the social justice
warrior left the the people who accuse
you of racism sexism that's just a small
fringe Dave Rubin I'm talking to you I
love you brother but I think you're
realizing it's not the regressive left
this is mainstream leftism I've always
talked about how leftists their
technique is to shut down dialog before
it begins through character
assassination so let's go before we get
to the arguments why does Barack Obama
not want to get to the arguments well
let's roll this clip just so I'm clear
tonight you're saying you would welcome
to me with the NRA I'm had Anderson I've
said this repeatedly I'm happy to meet
with I'm happy to talk to him but the
conversation has to be based on facts
and truth and what we're actually
proposing not some you know this
imaginary fiction in which Obama is
trying to take away your guns you see
what just happened there before we even
discuss anything Barack Obama has said
that the NRA and its supporters are
liars so before the gun owners come to
sit at the table and present our
arguments as Barack Obama is doing he's
already stacked the deck and you roll
you're liars I'm willing to talk about
it if you're just if you're gonna if
you're gonna be willing to talk about
truth
in fact so not some okay well what if we
present who's happy yeah whose facts
exactly Chris Kyle's wife was there we I
don't wanna play the clip it's too long
I will bring it up here on on YouTube I
guess further when people watch the
video well ok facts and statistics right
how about the fact that gun deaths have
gone down with increased gun ownership
in the United States how about the fact
that states with concealed carry have
far fewer attacks against civilians a
carjacking states that have looser gun
laws those are facts but Barack Obama
doesn't present those facts he presents
his opinion and says we'll only other
discussion if it takes place on an
honest playing field so right away he's
trying to accuse you of being a liar a
couple of things so then we'll get into
some of these arguments but I just want
to make sure you understand that right
off the bat what can you say to somebody
tonight to convince them that you don't
want to take away everybody's guns and
you're not coming for their guns well
first of all Anderson I think it's
useful to keep in mind I've been now
president for over seven years and gun
sales don't seem to have suffered during
that time if anything actually you've
helped David they've gone up I've been
very good for gun manufacturers more
importantly look I'll tell you a story
that I think indicates how I see the
issue back in 2007-2008 when I was
campaigning I'd leave Chicago a city
which is wonderful I couldn't be prouder
of my city you we're talking about
Chicago you couldn't be prouder of your
city Chicago and I know you're not
supposed to say that about the president
it's not polite but I just want to
reiterate Chicago I'm proud of it why
are you proud of Chicago Chicago has the
kind of gun control policies that you
want to implement we're not going to
talk about the Second Amendment and your
rights as an American today we've done a
video on that before we've talked about
it at great length right now we're
specifically addressing Barack Obama
okay so he goes into the fact that it's
a conspiracy we have this here really
quickly to call it a conspiracy I mean
well you're a lot of people really
believe this deeply that they just
don't know it just don't trust you I'm
sorry Gooper yes it is fair to call the
conspiracy what are you saying
are you suggesting that the notion that
we are creating a plot to take
everybody's guns away so that we can
have martial law there's certainly not a
conspiracy yes that is a conspiracy I
would hope that you would agree with it
is that controversy couple things there
that are really important we'll get to
the conspiracy in a second um I would
hope
don't tell a journalist what he should
or shouldn't think I know Anderson
Cooper will bend over for you along with
everyone else at the bar down in the
West Village and take your answer but
don't tell a journalist what he should
or shouldn't think I would hope and
that's why he bans fox news from
pressors because don't tell him what he
should or shouldn't think conspiracy
well it's again he's already painted gun
owners as Liars right as though we just
want to go out and have these machine
guns and we think that Barack Obama is
the queen and that we have no idea what
we're talking about well I've got it
right here Barack Obama praised the
Australian gun ban right got it up on
the screen his quote when Australia had
a mass killing it was just so shocking
to the system the entire country said
well we're going to completely change
our gun laws and they did and it hasn't
happened
that's his quote he was praising the
australia gun law now I know I'll get a
lot of leftist right no it wasn't a ban
it was a mandatory buyback program which
is a ban you can call whatever you want
mandatory buyback means you have a gun
you you're mandated to basically sell it
back to the government
it's like cash for clunkers for guns
only you had no choice so when Barack
Obama is praising an all-out gun ban in
Australia how is that conspiratorial for
someone who supports the Second
Amendment rights again we can have a
civil discussion about it you maybe
don't believe in the Second Amendment
Second Amendment I do but don't tell me
it's conspiratorial to go oh my gosh you
really you're a fan of that Australian
gun ban I think it was great
oh so you you want to ban guns now
you're being conspiracy theorists I know
you're just being crazy here does what
am I am i handsome what kind of what
kind of rabbit-hole did I jump into what
parallel universe am I in but here's one
thing - Barack Obama doesn't really
understand the Second Amendment or have
he's also admitted by the way he's never
owned a gun he's surrounded by Secret
Service men who own guns and use guns
but he's never owned a gun which may
imply that some of I thought it was
wordplay it may just be stupidity on the
automatic semi-automatic thing we'll get
into that but really quickly this is
what he considers to be conspiracy along
with his support of the Australian bun
gun ban what I think mark is alluding to
is what I said earlier this notion of a
conspiracy out there and it gets wrapped
up in concerns about the federal
government now there's a long history of
that that's in our DNA you know the
United States was was born suspicious of
some distant Network
okay now I don't want to do the
conservative thing where I just say see
he doesn't think that that it was a good
the American Revolution but he certainly
doesn't have the reverence for it and to
even use it as a conspiracy for modern
conspiracy theorists implies that
there's some kind of parallel can we all
agree it was legitimate the American
Revolutionary War that guns were
necessary can we all like it doesn't
seem that he agrees with that that's a
little bit nutty for me so when you
start off with other students pursue a
distant land and then you praise the
Australian gun ban I'm going okay okay
maybe maybe there's an issue here maybe
you do want to ban guns by the way let's
look at the results I have them here in
Australia the Australian gun ban
resulted in more guns than ever both
legal and illegal and the numbers aren't
in yet as far as the violent crime rate
okay so a couple things here are some
results we have this up on the screen
more guns never in Australia now let's
look at this he's also talked about how
nowhere else do they have these kinds of
shootings or mass homicides with guns
okay I understand it he points to Europe
Barack Obama prefers Europe he thinks
that Europe is doing very well right now
some would disagree Britain and Wales
now violent crimes for 100,000 I have
the chart up on screen 898 to 387 in the
United States so more guns are involved
with violent crimes
in the United States but violent crime
is overall higher now before you send
your hate mail I understand it's hard to
compare violent crime rates across
countries right we have a different
standard for violent crime same thing
with infanticide we consider babies to
be a part of in the infant mortality
rate that they just don't even count as
lives in most of Europe but the crime
rate may not be the I'll admit may not
be this much of a disparity between
Europe in the United States it may not
be 3 times more in Europe but the
violent crime rape and crying rape rape
will rape we can say rape Sweden's the
rape capital it was the worst slit but
Freud is Gettys in my brain through the
grave telling me and freedom in my
Germany so that's what's happening lots
of rape over there crime rate is at
least comparable so the removal of
rights of private citizens and at best
you end up with a comparable crime rate
now Barack Obama's never owned a gun so
we do have a clip of him roll it
even after San Bernardino they've
refused to make it harder for terror
suspects who can't get on a plane to buy
semi-automatic weapons and some gun
retailers are already stepping up by
refusing to finalize a purchase without
a complete background check or by
refraining from selling semi-automatic
weapons semi-automatic weapons ok to
those listening again if you've never
owned a gun semi-automatic weapons is a
gun where you handgun pull it pull a
bullet one trigger ok fully automatic
weapons machine guns are already illegal
they're inaccessible to all but a very
select few people with licenses so when
Barack Obama says that is it because
he's ignorant or is it because he
understands that semi-automatic is a
halfway a word from automatic and it
would be really easy to ban
semi-automatic weapons meaning all your
handguns all your hunting rifles
anything that's not a pump-action
shotgun or revolver would basically be
banned and I would bet they'd go after
revolvers because technically they're
double action but they act as semi
automatics this is the president he's
either stupid or lying we'll be back
louder with crowd or after this to
finish this up for you so glad to be
back we were talking about the Barack
Obama gun deal all right up let me go
macro on you a little bit here so we've
gotten into the
my big problem is Barack Obama is
painting anyone who opposes his by the
way it's a majority of the country it's
a majority of the country a majority of
the country even opposes the assault
weapons ban let alone the gun control
measures and you can call it sensible
gun control measures or common-sense gun
control measures all you want it's it's
irrelevant people oppose it it's a
single biggest losing issue for Barack
Obama
so when Barack Obama says well you know
how do people think I'm gonna be a
tyrant I'm not I'm only over another
year that's really listen he thinks
you're stupid that's what bothers me
he thinks he's so clever and you're an
idiot that you go well gee I guess the
only has a year then that's the end of
it the laws stay dummy think of
prohibition another poopoo you freely
witness I'm gonna talk about that right
now think of think of any law that was
horrific think of tax rates they stay
for a long time after a president is
gone the Bush tax cuts stayed with
Barack Obama for a long time so it's
silly it's disingenuous right he's try
well if you want to believe that me and
my only in a year left and I'm you no no
it's that if you enact an executive
action right now that could cause damage
for years to come it can pave the way
for Hillary Clinton to try and do
another assault weapons ban people
aren't it's just it assumes such
stupidity so you assume your audience is
stupid with that you you paint your
opposition as liars all only have it if
they want to talk on on facts with the
NRA so now you assume that you're in
your audience probably is stupid and
you've muddied the waters with
semi-automatic I've actually gotten
Jared I've gotten Corrections this week
where we did that mean that but but mr.
president fully automatic weapons are
already illegal and another
double-secret illegal
I received Corrections actually they're
not fully automatic weapons are
available since the assault weapons ban
was you dumbass I actually got at least
two dozen corrections fully automatic
weapons are not legal for the average
now if you're a heavily armoured vehicle
they can but that's not what they mean
to say they mean to say semi-automatic
weapon
someone who's never fired a gun someone
who's never owned a gun as Barack Obama
has admitted himself now not a Secret
Service mind you doesn't know that one
trigger pull one bullet
that's semi-automatic handgun bang bang
bang semi-automatic leftists want to ban
bang bang semi-automatic not one trigger
pol a bazillion Gillian bullets one
trigger pull bang revolvers even your
old six-shooter revolver technically two
double action but for all intents and
purposes it's the intents and purposes
intents and purposes it acts as a
semi-automatic is just a slightly
heavier trigger pull so to give you an
idea let me who does that effect okay
got a story right up here we wrote about
it at lotto with credit calm sixty five
year old grandmother shot a would-be
mugger let me read this for you this
just happened this week Barack Obama
wants to cry his his tears and elicit an
emotional reaction let me give you the
other side 65 year-old woman described
as 4 foot 11 inches 105 pounds
technically a [ __ ] by the way I had a
friend it was a [ __ ] who got [ __ ]
money for college
you get like a grant really it's under 5
foot you get the [ __ ] money anyone out
there if I let out in your paperwork if
you're 5 foot you know like just wear
flats hunched a little bit get your
[ __ ] money Uncle Sam's none the wiser
so on the way home from a gas station
four-foot inches now there was a man
mugger bun a cheese bun Nate bond tates
I don't know I don't know how to
pronounce this thing guy was 5 foot 11
200 pounds tried to mug her and she shot
him shot him he fell to the ground right
away she called 911 the emergency so she
had a pistol she'd a legal concealed
carry license here's what I want you to
do with me for a second let's go through
this go through a checklist ok this is
actually pretty typical of many American
gun owners and millions of people every
year defend themselves with guns and
stop rapings or killings who does it
benefit the most people like the 65 year
old lady who has no fighting chance
against a 200-pound virile young man
without a firearm that's why it's a
great equalizer did she have a legally
owned firearm check legally valid
concealed permit Chuck was she vigilant
of her surroundings she watched this guy
follow her home check that's the first
thing they teach you in concealed carry
course the best offense is a
is actually a being aware before
anything happens the best defense is
being aware of your surroundings being
vigilant and avoiding bad situations did
she take the appropriate measures
immediately following the altercation
called the cops check I want you to take
that and cross-reference that checklist
with criminals with let's say the mugger
do you think let's go through that you
think he had a legally owned firearm
would you check that do you think he had
a legally valid concealed carry
concealed carry permit check do you
think he probably was vigilant of his
surroundings cuz he's spotting the
person to rape or in this case my guy I
mean no no I'm sure 60 federal ladies
get ready to um do you think he would
take the appropriate measures to notify
the authorities
so let's cross-reference the checklist
with most gun owning Americans with a
criminal and you start to see why
Americans get a little bit irked alright
so we have a what else do we have here I
had one more thing to talk about with um
oh one thing did you notice that Barack
Obama said he would not support any
candidate who didn't support
common-sense gun I did reform I did hear
that I didn't think about what that
really I think it's a subtle swipe at
Bernie because Bernie Sanders is the
only Democrat who's only had running
right now who's only had a d-minus
rating from the NRA
remember they read him the riot act of
Vermont at the DNC debate yeah yeah they
were furious with him because he had a
d-minus and Hillary Clinton was I have a
F F to my my F - yeah - gotta eat I even
got an F for effort they did a little
commentary with the effort you know like
Hillary Clinton kind of F but she got
out she got a uh works well with others
you know report cards did you get those
notes in your car Alice home schools now
I did well I got disruptive and or
abusive no loud and abusive loud and
abusive those the term my dad used
allowed an abuse in class a lot abuse a
with crowder an abused him with crowder
so he's proud of Chicago supports the
gun that couldn't the gun banned from
Australia and paints everyone who
disagrees with him as a liar and he has
no idea as to the difference between a
semi-automatic or an automatic weapon
he has never owned a gun this is the guy
you want signing executive actions and
to mention the millet that Lenny
millions but the the tons of times he
said these are first steps right these
are first step I'm sorry you know so and
really important to note whenever
elaborating on what next steps were when
he says this is my only those are my
only you're my only your left exactly
when you're when your neck was on a line
for election or re-election you didn't
bring it up because it's an
overwhelmingly losing issue for
Democrats the only reason he's doing it
now he can't push it through he can't do
it properly the constitutional way has
to be an executive action because it's
unpopular and he would lose he's a
coward louder with Crowder stay tuned oh
it's you glad to see you again if you
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face or the button above hey remember
that time when I said I was glad to see
you again I lied